j'aime ici mais où est ce qu'on appelle
un navigateur 8000 nous il est d'autres
autochtones comme cette algue aucun qui
vit dans la rue et qui souffre d'un
cancer
à ce moment là je fais de la compagnie
la glace
selon plusieurs experts ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux dans les rues de
montréal
je suis venu ici en vacances il y a
trois ans nous disent et inuits
je suis venu me faire soigner et je ne
veux plus retourner à coups de joueurs
apic d'illizi elle a même retrouvé son
fils dans les rues de montréal
je découvre montréal dit le jeune inuit
daniel autochtone d'abitibi porte les
marques de ces bagarres parce que vivre
dans la rue est souvent très difficile
j'aime ici mais on oriente les
autochtones qu'ils veulent vers les
services médicaux ou à l'enrôler mais
beaucoup au niveau médical donc pas d
accompagner le réseau santé ou encore à
la clinique mobile de médecins du monde
jimmy accompagne cette femme à la
pharmacie pour qu'elle puisse avoir des
médicaments et sa collègue claudine
proposa un autre tokten de se rendre
chez le dentiste
à côté une infirmière vaccine autres
patients issus d'une première nation des
soins de base difficile à obtenir pour
les sans abri autochtone qui souvent
n'ont pas les cartes et documents
nécessaires
donc c'est de faire valoir ce droit leur
d'accès aux soins d'accès aux
médicaments d'accès aux services et il
ya aussi la cohabitation parfois
complexes avec le reste de la population
salut
contraint de beaucoup
ici jimmy tente de calmer commerçante
excédés par la présence d'itinérants
autochtone c'est beaucoup lié à
l'ignorance l'alpha et enseigna à
l'ignorance mais des situations où on
est confronté à du racisme c'est
constante pour l'instant jimmy est l'un
des deux seuls navigateur autochtone
médecins du monde souhaite en ajouter un
troisième bientôt et se retire et
éventuellement de ce programme
étrangement une intention c'est
transmettre ce projet là un organiste
autochtone éventuellement surtout que
l'itinérance autochtone ne disparaîtra
pas de sitôt
je ne veux pas retourner chez moi johnny
nées au lac mistassini
comme d'autres il fuit les problèmes de
sa communauté et recréer ici à montréal
un petit groupe d'autochtones expatriés
ici david gêne-t-il radio canada
montréal
[Musique]